easy to feel daunted by the scale of the
challenge that we face by sea levels
rising droughts and wildfires spreading
people forced out of their homes
but i look around this hall and i feel
optimism
why because this
is the first cop
to bring together so many of the world's
finance ministers businesses and
investors with such a clear common
purpose
to deliver the promise
made in paris six years ago
to direct the world's wealth to protect
our planet
the good news is that the will is there
at least 80 percent of the global
economy has committed to net zero or
carbon neutrality targets
our challenge now
is to deploy the investment we need to
deliver those targets around the world
to do so we are accelerating three
actions today
first
we need increased public investment
and i want to speak directly to the
developing countries of the world
we know that you've been devastated by
the double tragedies of coronavirus and
climate change
that's why the g20 is stepping up to
provide debt treatments more swiftly
it's why the imf are providing a new 650
billion dollar allocation of special
drawing rights and crystalline we'll say
more on this later
and it's why we're going to meet the
target
to provide a hundred billion dollars of
climate finance to developing countries
and while we know
we are not yet meeting it soon enough we
will work closely with developing
countries to do more and to reach the
target sooner
over the next five years we will deliver
a total of 500 billion dollars of
investment to the countries that need it
most
and we can do more today
i can announce that the united kingdom
will commit a hundred million pounds to
the task force on access to climate
finance making it quicker and easier for
developing countries to access the
finance they need
and we're supporting a new capital
markets mechanism which will issue
billions of new green bonds here in the
uk to fund renewable energy in
developing countries
two tangible practical examples
of how we're delivering our promise of a
hundred billion dollars
but public investment alone isn't enough
our second action is to mobilize private
finance
let me pay an enormous tribute to mark
carney for his leadership leadership
that is delivering results
the glasgow financial alliance for net
zero has now brought together financial
organizations with assets worth over 130
trillion dollars of capital to be
deployed
this is a historic wall of capital for
the net zero transition around the world
what matters now is action
to invest that capital in our low carbon
future
to do that investors need to have as
much clarity and confidence in the
climate impact of their investments
as they do in the traditional financial
metrics of profit and loss
so our third action is to rewire the
entire global financial system for net
zero
better and more consistent climate data
sovereign green bonds mandatory
sustainability disclosures proper
climate risk surveillance stronger
global reporting standards all things we
need to deliver
and i'm proud that the uk
is playing its part
we've already made it mandatory for
businesses to disclose climate related
financial information
with 35 other countries signing up to do
the same
today i'm announcing that the uk will go
further
and become the first ever net zero
aligned financial center
this means
we are going to move towards making it
mandatory for firms to publish a clear
deliverable plan
setting out how they will decarbonize
and transition to net zero with an
independent task force to define what's
required
so
a renewed pledge to a hundred billion
dollars a year of public funding over
130 trillion dollars of private capital
waiting to be deployed
and a greener financial system underway
six years ago paris set the ambition
today in glasgow we're providing the
investment we need to deliver that
ambition
now i know when people hear about global
finance it can often feel remote and
abstract
but we're not simply talking about
numbers on a page
we're talking about making a tangible
difference to people's lives about cheap
reliable and clean electricity to power
schools and hospitals in rural africa
about better coastal defenses in the
philippines in the pacific islands to
protect people from storm surges
about everyone everywhere having fresher
water to drink cleaner air to breathe
better insulated homes in which to live
that's the vision we're asking you to
commit to that's the opportunity we're
asking you to invest in
and that's the work that we're asking
you to begin
today
thank you